hola qué tal bienvenidos una vez más a
esta a este encuentro semanal con canadá
en las américas café el castor
cibernético el reencuentro que cada
siete días le proponemos desde aquí
desde el servicio en español de radio
canadá internacional hoy estamos aquí en
el estudio
rufo valencia pablo gómez barrios y
leonardo gimeno mi nombre es luis
laborda y les recordamos a todos ustedes
que nos pueden seguir como es habitual
en vivo a través de nuestro sitio en
internet www rc y net punto sea pero
también a través de facebook live y
saludamos a todos nuestros oyentes
públicos compañeros colegas compinches
etcétera etcétera
me encanta pablo en el centro del
estadio en el mundo
pero también recuerda que nos puede
decir en vivo a través de nuestro sitio
de internet
mejor dicho de nuestro sitio de youtube
donde la emisión también se encuentra en
vivo y donde vamos teniendo semana a
semana cada vez más oyentes como es un
hábito ya ponemos nuestra misión los
días viernes en nuestra página de radio
canadá internacional en español y pueden
acceder al contenido del programa
durante todo el fin de semana y hasta el
lunes por la mañana que tal como están
todos ustedes muy bien muy bien acá
mirando el fútbol con una sobredosis de
fútbol aparentemente bien aparentemente
absoluta
no estoy hablando de ti absolutamente
bien y no es solamente en apariencias
bueno pues que porque estamos esperando
a que los resultados del partido del
domingo baja a de colombia contra
polonia entonces por eso digo
aparentemente bien y que polvito tienes
para ese encuentro dado que vamos a
atenas
ganar 200 colombia gana 20
bien bien aquí justamente apoyando a los
equipos que nunca han ganado una copa
como por ejemplo como marruecos como
irán como nigeria que está jugando este
momento contra islandia 0 y sí y liga no
además a polonia de 2 a 1
así que y sobre todo sorprendido por los
resultados de las potencias
futbolísticas latinoamericanas en un
brasil que hoy día marcó justamente en
los últimos minutos del yate sobre
tiempo un tiempo extras en tiempo extra
entonces y la gran herida para américa
latina después argentina no así que
bueno que de uruguay costa rica hace
maletas igual que perú
entonces ahí ya banca es como el trabajo
de edición nos van cayendo
se van editando en los equipos bueno a
heridas o no heridas porque eso
dependerá de la postura y del entender
de cada uno volveremos un poco más tarde
porque por supuesto el mundial nos
atraviesa nosotros como a todo el mundo
la mayoría tenemos oyentes y seguidores
que no comparten ese fervor mundialista
sí pero en términos por endo comparado
con el fútbol americano con el béisbol
cualquier deporte desde de ultra
mercadeo que conocemos aquí en américa
de norte el fútbol el nuestro pues deja
deja deja minúsculos deja de la talla de
una hormiga estos deportes que aquí
tienen tanta tanta tanta importante
bueno era la expansión geográfica es
mucho más importante en lo que nosotros
llamamos fútbol y aquí llaman soccer que
respecto de otros deportes no es cierto
aunque el tema de mercadeo se va
haciendo sin además presentes esperando
tienen
pero por ejemplo para el hockey para el
fútbol americano
tienes comprarte una armadura común como
un caballero medieval para entrar a
jugar el cine sin esas cosas no hay
deportes antes en cambio el fútbol es es
un ballet siempre se ha dicho que el
fútbol y el boxeo beatbox son dos
actividades que están abiertas tanto a
personas con un alto poder adquisitivo
como a los que vienen en la más extrema
pobreza porque porque necesitas más que
ganas para practicarlos netflix
presentase poco un documental sobre tela
y justamente para ilustrar esa historia
ajá y el que decía al respecto bueno
pelees veces es su vida es como cuando
todavía se acuerda de bueno era pobre
pues mira él era un documental
así que había actores pelé no estaba de
precio y me acuerdo de sus televisores
colorado rq un momento se metió a ser
televisores creo bueno perfecto vamos a
volver más tarde al fútbol que hagamos o
no creamos porque de hecho estamos
pendientes de algunos resultados que son
importantes para más de una selección
nos apasiona a los que estamos sentados
aquí en la micro no nombraremos por el
momento por el momento pero ya las vamos
a tener que nombrar quedamos no
querramos y respecto a los temas que les
han llamado la atención al margen de
este torneo mundial de fútbol campeonato
mundial el fútbol de la fifa rusia 2018
cuáles son los temas fuera de la
estricta actualidad que te han llamado
la atención en los últimos días si es
que alguno les ha llamado la atención
algo curioso que haya acaparó la
atención de ustedes que les hayan
sorprendido sí sí sí sí yo tengo uno
pues que vi ahorita en nuestro sitio en
el sitio de radio canadá y es que esta
mañana temprano alrededor de las 4 de la
mañana un camión que iba circulando por
la autopista 401 que como sabemos es la
que va hacia el oeste
por toronto que acaba justo un poco
antes de llegar a toronto un camión que
iba a transportando yo
se estrelló contra al parecer el chófer
está acusado está acusado de manejar de
una forma peligrosa en todo caso sé no
sé cómo hizo el asunto fue que el camión
se volcó y todos los yogures se relajan
en la autopista 401 en una de las varias
de las vías de la a-401 nada menos que
en la 400 un exacto entonces lo cual
provocó una famosa vía norte a un
congestionamiento prácticamente era eso
provocó un congestionamiento monstruo
porque bueno a las 7 a las 4 de la
mañana a las cuando eres prácticamente
comienza en la hora pico sí sí sí en que
todo el mundo va a trabajar si ese
entonces pues se se armó hay todo un
problema y pues tardó en restablecerse
el tráfico en la ciudad de toronto y
cerraron la 401 durante s
ese es ahora ahora es ahora una de las
autopistas más importantes de esa parte
del país no quiero ni imaginar lo que
debe haber sido intentar llegar al
trabajo con yogur además por todos lados
pero ayer había habido también un
accidente importante no no no no tengo
los detalles no escuché la noticia
completa pero hubo un accidente
importante con un auto o un camión que
también se prendió fuego
aquí en autopista 40 aquí en montreal y
además hubo también un accidente si no
me equivoco en el que una persona fue
arrollada creo que eso fue antes de ayer
así que a mí lo que me llama la atención
y no es novedad y pasa casi todos los
veranos pero este verano ha sido
realmente verano el verano cae dentro de
dos semanas un día no es la cantidad de
construcción no se puede ir a ningún
lado en la ciudad de montreal eso no
ocurre únicamente en el verano aquí no
no no pero en el verano es absurdo no se
puede ir a ningún lado yo para llegar a
mi casa
desde la autopista hasta mi casa tengo
cinco minutos en auto bueno pero tardé
45 minutos para llegar sabes que una de
las hipótesis que he escuchado es que
esta supuesta proliferación de
accidentes y es que realmente existe una
proliferación de accidentes se produce
en parte debido a que la gente o algunas
personas al menos están perdiendo un
poco la paciencia
gracias a este estilo me junto de obras
que hacen que el tránsito sea más
complicado no me extrañaría algo que hay
hay calles donde uno dobla y le hacen
hacerla aún la misma calle para volver
para poder salir por el lugar donde
entró en vez de decir no no doble parada
porque no el lugar también ha pasado más
de una vez de dar vueltas a la manzana y
encontrarme luego en el mismo sitio
decir pero y quien dice me hagan algún
tipo de aviso díganle a la gente lo que
pasa no todas las control al mismo
tiempo que dice en su casa no exacto es
genial
tenemos a nuestros amigos oyentes cómo
es el tráfico en sus ciudades y
tienen sus problemas si tienen cómo
encontrar este festival del cono naranja
que dura todo el año sino solamente en
montreal digamos que américa del norte
en general al menos las grandes urbes
tienen la fama de ser más que
complicadas para la circulación de autos
no hay quienes dicen por ejemplo que uno
puede perder tranquilamente tres horas
para ir y tres horas para volver en su
auto si por ejemplo tiene que ir al
centro de los ángeles y vive en la
periferia de esa ciudad aquí creo que no
es tan grave la cosa todavía aunque sí
me ha pasado de mi palo lo sabe porque
lo hemos hablado más graves en mi caso
particular mi caso personal de renunciar
por ejemplo a venir en auto a la radio
porque ya en el momento en imposible no
solamente atravesar los puentes que unen
la ribera sur donde yo vivo con la
ciudad de montreal sino ya llegar al
puente no hay aparte la historia de la
cantidad de construcciones
e impiden también estacionar o sea uno
tampoco encuenta estacionamientos y yo
la última vez que viene en auto a este
trabajo y buenas afueras de montreal
hacia el oeste de la isla la última vez
que viene en auto tarde una hora 20
minutos en encontrar estacionamiento
o sea sin contar lo que tarde en el
viaje del viaje pongo una hora y fácil y
media tranquilamente y encima una hora y
media más para conseguir estacionalmente
o sea es realmente ridículo y ahora que
ya comienzan en pocos días más grandes
festivales en el centro de la ciudad de
montreal como por ejemplo el festival de
jazz van a cortar encima para el domingo
hermoso fue el aquí se hace una vez por
año el tour de lille
es una un recorrido en bicicleta por
toda la isla de montreal y cierra las
calles para que la gente esté segura ni
se te ocurra sacar el tour de monde de
montreal porque es el tour de la
bicicleta
de 60 km
no sé si están tres horas de eddie tres
horas de vuelta si son seis horas eso
significa que la persona pasa
exactamente 91 días las 24 horas en el
auto
91 días de su vida en el auto de 360
días y sus noches por esa razón yo
decidí desde hace mucho tiempo de que yo
no me iba a la periferia como es el caso
de todos ustedes que viven en las
afueras de montreal no en todos casos es
una elección de mayor información en la
billetera menor yo vivo en montreal y me
vengo en bicicleta me lleva media hora
venir en bicicleta a la pista la
ciclovía pasa detrás de mi casa y pasa
delante de radio canadá entonces pues yo
me económico esos 91 días que lo utilizo
de otra forma así sí bueno también es
cierto que por ejemplo en mi caso
personal cuando yo compré mi casa en la
ribera sur con su pequeño jardín eran
pequeños jardines detrás y espacios en
las casas es cierto por todo lo que
ustedes quieran por el valor que yo
pague por esa casa en su momento aquí en
montreal no conseguía absolutamente
y yo no tengo el problema de criar hijos
porque no los tengo pero las familias
que tienen que optar por criar a hijos y
con el poder adquisitivo que tienen en
el momento de la compra sólo pueden
acceder a un pequeñísimo apartamento en
la ciudad y no siempre en el centro y la
decisión es casi como obligada uno tiene
que buscar otros espacios este y si no
los consiguen montreal los consiguen
otra parte el terrible problema es que
acá en esta mesa hay un rico y tres
pobres
[Risas]
también también otro tema que me quemé
que me llamó la atención por - a mí es
que hoy se celebra de una manera un poco
extraño porque no sé quién ha
introducido esta celebración propiamente
dicha
hoy se celebra el día internacional de
el día mundial mejor dicho de llevar el
perro al trabajo pero fort no trajiste
tu perro que pasó no el perro estaba que
tampoco
problemas
yo no sabía que en verdad el 22 de junio
se celebra el día mundial de llevar el
perro al trabajo una tendencia que
parece que gana cada vez más adeptos en
distintas partes del mundo y que según
algunos estudios señalan tienen sus
beneficios por ejemplo en el plano
psicológico de los trabajadores y en la
convivencia dentro del ámbito laboral
qué tal qué harían ustedes traerían al
súper de trabajo
mi perra duraría 15 segundos al látex
porque es muy inquieta entonces
extraerla sería como una especie de
locura duraría 15 segundos la perra o tu
paciencia en mi paciente la paciencia de
los demás con respecto a mi guerra y mía
con respecto a mi perra y con respecto a
los demás manuales no sería una buena
idea
bueno pues mi perrita lo es esta viejita
tiene como 14 años más o menos
y la ex tranquila de ella
y hace lo que es lo que prefiere hacer
que dormir todo el día así que no
hubiera podido traer incluso meterle en
el cajón del escritorio con una cubierta
y hubiera estado muy bien ahí es que se
permiten animales en este edificio
no se permite aquí no nos permitan a las
edificios públicos no sé de hecho ahora
que ahora que recuerdo
hay una viñeta por lo menos en la
portada que yo ingreso habitualmente
aquí sobre la calle walls que señala que
está prohibido el acceso de perros de
hecho he visto ya perros a que el
interior por me imagino que la orden
médica de apoyo psicológico exacto si
pudieras traerías a tu perro golden
retriever
a tu lugar de trabajo porque justamente
uno de los uno y esto lo sabemos todos
hay informes médicos hay estudios que
indican que estar sentado es mortal a
largo plazo
inclusive teníamos tenemos instrucciones
de que por cada por cada hora trabajada
por cada 50 minutos trabajados en crema
nadies entonces con un perro sería
fantástico poder adaptarnos vueltas por
acá pero si el perro se va de mambo como
diríamos si te hace caminar de la hora
te hace caminar 50 minutos y solo
en el caso de que la verdad que es un
excelente perro nunca ha destrozado nada
en mi casa no es agresivo es muy
cariñoso con la familia con los extraños
a veces demasiado cariñoso con los niños
ni que decirlo pero a la hora de querer
desplegar actividad hay que seguirle el
tren y no es nada fácil yo creo que si
lo trajese aquí a la radio poco tiempo
sería el que realmente podría dedicarle
a trabajar
y
no creo que sea tan fácil la convivencia
entre los animales y las personas sobre
todo cuando aquí hay muchísima gente que
no tiene animales y cuando el animal no
es de uno no sé si uno tiene la misma
predisposición para soportar el
comportamiento de ese animal como lo
tiene con el propio
además hay toda esta cuestión de las
alergias y quizá un elemento fundamental
para que nuestros siguientes te vean un
poco algunos rasgos de esta relación
entre humanos y animales y perros en
canadá es que debido justamente al clima
los perros a diferencia de la latina
america latina mucho en muchos casos los
perros viven viven viven pero en casas
en la casa pero viven afuera viven viven
puertas afuera digamos en casa para
entrar en una ciudad no ya bueno
entonces quizás porque porque cuando uno
tiene una casa ya realmente no un
apartamento una casa y hay patios el
patio está la calle está cercada
entonces es esa diferencia en cambio que
uno tiene que vivir con el perro bajo
como techo las 24 horas del día y son
todo en invierno sí claro así que
entonces la dinámica de la relación es
muy distinta eso quiere decir que tu
perro no sabe durante los inviernos
claro que sale de esto de obligada
salida y entonces cómo se comporta muy
bien muy bien es un perro que pues ese
es realmente es el mismo mi consejero
político en realidad
cuando tengo que ir aportar en
decisiones al perro porque ha sabido
elegir al mejor candidato si te gustan
las plantas color naranja habrá que
preguntarle a nuestros escucha veedores
seguir como éste es un día mundial si
tuvieran la oportunidad de llevar a su
perro al trabajo si lo harían entonces
la pregunta está lanzada y aprovechó la
y aprovechó la ocasión para decir que
juan carlos miranda duarte está
esta escucha viéndonos en este momento
js sevilla dice saludos desde colombia
nuestra colega paloma martínez dice
vamos nigeria que no está muy lejos de
aquí y nigeria ya van 2 a 0
jugando tanto en que le van a dar a
argentina 3 a 0 próximo
y gilberto martínez dice canadá en las
américas saludo felicitó por la
entrevista que le hicieron a una
nicaragüense de la situación que vive
nicaragua bueno perfecto vamos a ir una
pequeña pausa y ya continuamos con
canadá en las américas café
[Música]
bueno perfecto y antes de meternos en
los temas que hemos ido trabajando a lo
largo de esta semana aquí en la sección
en español los invito a leer algunos de
los mensajes que nos han llegado en los
últimos días en las últimas dos semanas
porque la semana pasada casi no leímos o
no leímos ningún mensaje si no me
equivoco los mensajes que nos hacen
llegar nuestros oyentes a nuestro sitio
en internet
yo aquí tengo uno y dice bueno los temas
destacados esta semana dos instituciones
cadencias ofrecen becas para aprender
inglés a mujeres de américa latina es
una noticia realizada por leonora
chapman y dice la academia de lenguas de
canadá y la acc y la alianza de negocios
hispano canadiense shb a ofrecen también
becas para mujeres de habla hispana que
quieren estudiar inglés en canadá en las
ciudades de toronto y vancouver esta
iniciativa que tiene por objetivo dar en
mano
profesionalmente hablando a las mujeres
de habla hispana que quieran volar de
sus propias alas y para quienes el
aprendizaje del inglés resultaría
ventajoso en el sector de que se
proponen evolucionar entonces este es el
mensaje que nos escribían por dos
instituciones canadienses ofrecen becas
para aprender
solo y con respecto a la noticia canadá
invita a una docena de naciones
adicionales a la cumbre del g7 que fue
el pasado a principios del mes de junio
rodrigo venga gamarra y cuervo dice en
efecto es sorprendente el listado de
países invitados por canadá a la 44
cumbre anual del g7 esmeril es meritorio
que se tenga como tema relevante entre
otros no menos importante la protección
de los océanos y la preservación de la
pesca estos dos grandes temas están
interrelacionados entre sí pues la
protección de los océanos implica de
hecho la preservación y conservación de
las especies ello incluye la playa la
pesca planificada coordinada y
controlada era un comentario de rodrigo
vega gamarra y cuervo aquí tenemos una
nota muy muy puntual que han reactivado
justamente al mundial pero lo que es
interesante es el tema es que nada en su
plan de inmigración 2018 pero nuestro
oyente mike el mar
de cuba es bueno pues me imagino porque
la dirección electrónica es nauta punto
ce
él dice buenos días este es un problema
propio de países subdesarrollados que no
tienen idea del inmenso valor del
deporte para el beneficio de la
humanidad esas ofensas que hacen los
hinchas mexicanos a los porteros del
equipo rival también lo hacen en otros
países del continente americano a quien
me suele es igual en algunos estadios se
hoy esas mismas groserías insultos y
vulgaridades de los hinchas en un
partido de fútbol inclusive en las
eliminatorias mundialistas imagínense un
niño que vaya a un estadio a ver un
partido de fútbol y lo primero que
aprende es a decir esas vulgaridades
cuando ese niño se convierta en un
adulto perdón la repetirá por eso es que
muchos padres se cohíben de llevar a sus
familias a estos eventos aunado a esto
lanzan la cerveza por los aires cuando
el equipo anfitrión anotó un gol es un
desastre que hacer para erradicar este
flagelo de los estadios no sólo multar a
los equipos sino
si no utilizar sanciones más severas
tales como vetar los estadios por varias
fechas según la gravedad del caso pero
el equipo no buscará una sede neutral
sino que jugará en la sede de su rival
de turno es decir un equipo infractor
tendrá que jugar los partidos de ida y
vuelta en la sede de su adversario hasta
que cumpla con la sanción de forma
escrita cada vez que la hinchada tenga
un mal comportamiento se le quitará al
equipo los puntos obtenidos en el
partido las confederaciones y la fifa
deben supervisar el desarrollo de los
partidos de fútbol en las ligas de los
países que representan y advertirles a
las federaciones
existen filtraciones compresas dice
entre paréntesis que de continuar con
estos hechos en los estadios sus
selecciones no participarán en las
limitadas
eliminatorias del mundial refrán popular
a los hinchas o corren o se encaraman
dice justamente michael marrero nauta
punto se q quien nos escribe desde
venezuela perfecto y yo tengo por mi
parte un mensaje muy breve que nos hace
llegar llegar un oyente de sobrenombre
golf class que se refiere a una a una
nota creo que tú ya pablo que es la
segunda feria del libro en español de
vancouver mi fe y yo dice que buena
pinta tiene esa feria cuando es si no me
equivoco es el 14 de octubre que se
lleva a cabo la segunda la segunda
presentación que había de esta feria yo
estuve conversando con la persona que lo
organiza y la fecha no no me acuerdo
exactamente ahora si era el 14 pero sí
sé que es en el mes de octubre a
mediados de octubre se va a llevar a
cabo esta segunda edición de la feria
del libro en español de vancouver que le
ha llamado la atención a nuestros
oyentes golf
y si no tiene la nota producida por
pablo donde hay figurará seguramente con
claridad la fecha de realización un
mensaje más bien un mensaje más con el
calor extremo en el polo norte en quitas
científicos daniela o saunier nos dice
las personas solemos jugar con el cambio
climático como si no fuera algo serio sé
que esto tendría que pasar tarde o
temprano pero me gustaría que las
personas involucrar más en el tema los
científicos hacen un gran trabajo
informándonos al respecto y obteniendo
predicciones pero nosotros que estamos
haciendo dice ya quemando basura
ignorando el tema o jugando la
naturaleza es nuestra madre y además
compartimos el planeta con los animales
a algunas personas no les llega a
importar pero si ellos les afecta a
nosotros más la solución no es buscar
otro planeta para vivir sino hacer lo
posible y hasta lo imposible para que
nuestro presente hogar sea un lugar sano
y habitable verde y habitable para las
futuras generaciones un futuro gal no es
una próxima tumba dice este mensaje de
daniela
mientras escuchábamos con una atención
total que el equipo de islandia acaba de
marrar un penal
82 conseguido para el bar por el famoso
bar que ya comienza a tener su peso en
su peso en este mundial
y bueno justamente nuestra amiga y
susana ochoa beca que fue terminada aquí
la semana pasada
ella nos dice saludos desde charleroi
entonces ésta está viéndonos en este
momento damos un cordial saludo también
no sé si pablo había leído el saludo
desde colombia de jota de sevilla bueno
decía sólo saludos a todos y bueno vamos
a hacerle una reseña como es habitual a
nuestros oyentes de cuáles son los temas
que hemos trabajado a lo largo de esta
semana y en particular cuál es el que
les recomendamos con prioridad en todo
caso
bueno con respecto a lo que yo produje
esta semana tiene que ver justamente con
el mundial y con esto de que si ya está
considerado como la copa del mundo más
innovadora e innovadora desde el punto
de vista tecnológico por bueno un montón
de cosas como por ejemplo la pelota
inteligente es una pelota de un chip
adentro ese llama es un chip muy
particular porque se activa en realidad
no es para el mundial pero estuvo
generada para el mundial uno lo activa
con su computador entonces dice cuánto
se jugó hoy un montón de datos pero en
realidad es para uso más casero que
dentro del mundial y dentro del mundial
ejemplo las cuestiones de las
acreditaciones que tienen un fan aid y
que está montado con una base de datos
para poder de esta manera tener un
control exhaustivo de la gente que
participa es mundial
el otro día bueno salió un vídeo de la
de los japoneses que limpiaban el
estadio inmediatamente después de
terminar el partido y había gente que
decía no es fake son gente contratada
miren tienen un haití esa es la idea del
funk o sea son eran fanáticos que sí
hicieron eso inmediatamente después del
partido
y esto también para cuestiones de
prevención en cuanto a la cantidad
enorme de amenazas terroristas que se
registraron antes del comienzo de este
mundial y bueno después la filial aitor
la falsificación exacto exacto para las
entradas por supuesto y la
la emisión en ultra 4k y con 36
cámaras de ultra definición en cada uno
de los ángulos de la cancha y por
ejemplo la utilización del bar que es la
primera vez que se utiliza este tipo de
revisión que en realidad no es que se
revisen todas jugadas hay cuatro
elementos particulares para el bar que
tiene que ver con cuando hay un error
arbitral por ejemplo uno no reconoce al
dar paso el puesto de amarilla a un
jugador y había era otro que había
cometerá falta esto se volvió le anula
la amarilla al jugador y le pone la
tarjeta amarilla al otro para corroborar
los goles por ejemplo para los penaltis
por ejemplo o para cuando hay algún
problema que tiene que ver con la
definición si el gol fue válido o no
esas son las cuatro posibilidades es
decir no porque uno haga un full en la
mitad de la cancha se va a ir a
registrar con el bar en el bar es sólo
para cuatro cuestiones puntuales y esto
bueno todas estas cosas que tienen que
ver con tecnología son las que dictan
que la copa de rusia 2018 ya es
considerada la más tecnológica de la
historia
y bueno pues algo que se estaba
esperando y que sucedió esta semana fue
la legalización de la marihuana aquí en
canadá
contrariamente a lo que había prometido
el primer ministro yo esté en trudeau
que entraría en vigencia a partir del
primero de julio no se pudo pero va a
entrar en vigencia a partir del 17 de
octubre ya eso está decidido él se había
anunciado y era sabía de alguna forma
esperado una especie de pulso entre el
senado canadiense y la cámara de
representantes porque ellos se exigían
que se estudiara ese proyecto de ley y
que absolutamente tenía que estar listo
para que entrara en vigencia justamente
el primero de julio pero bueno los
después de haberlo estudiado los
senadores los enviaron nuevamente a la
cámara de representantes para que lo
estudiarán con 46 enmiendas de una de
esas enmiendas de hecho la principal
según algunos senadores era
la que le pedía al gobierno que dejara a
las provincias legislar en cuanto a un
tema bien particular que es el cultivo
de a domicilio de hablar de gas de
marihuana la ley
lc 45 dice que se le permite en el país
en todo el país en canadá a las personas
a cultivar cuatro plantas en su casa si
quebec la provincia de manitoba y el
territorio de nunavut no estaban de
acuerdo con eso quebec sigue no estando
de acuerdo pero el gobierno de acuerdo
con la cantidad una de acuerdo con la
producción que hacer con la producción
casera con la producción casera ellos
ellos dicen que tendría que ser las
provincias y que ve que no quiere que se
haga esa producción en casa entonces
pues se anunciaba hay una especie de
pulso que no hubo finalmente porque el
gobierno no aceptó ese enmienda y la
regreso nuevamente
al senado y bueno finalmente el senado
se plegó a la cámara de representantes y
aceptó esta semana aprobó el proyecto de
ley
entre otras cosas una de las cosas que
lamentan hay una senadora que fue
entrevistada por radio en la radio
francesa de radio canadá que ella decía
que otra enmienda importante que no se
aprobó es
de que que se le prohibiera a las
compañías que producen el cut que
cultivan la marihuana para vendérsela al
gobierno que se les prohibiera la
promoción donde de hacer campañas de
promoción de este producto y eso tampoco
fue pasó en el gobierno quiere decir que
las compañías no pueden lo pueden hacer
y lo que yo no entiendo es por ejemplo
porque dan el ok para que la promoción
se puede hacer promoción publicitaria y
la promoción publicitaria de los
cigarrillos ahora está casi casi fuera
de todo donde toda posibilidad digamos
sea yo entiendo que el cigarrillo es el
comprobado científicamente el causante
de un montón de tipos de cáncer y que
colabora con otros tipos de cáncer para
desarrollarse igualmente
la marihuana algún tipo porque por
ejemplo uno de los elementos más
venenosos del cigarrillo es la
combustión del papel y es donde se pone
la marihuana o sea también papel o sea
probablemente lo hay pipas ahora
a lo que voy es el porqué de abrir de
tal manera esta posibilidad de campañas
publicitarias y cerrarla para otros
tipos de empresas no al parecer porque
juzgan más nocivo el tabaco que la
marihuana me imagino yo en todo caso lo
que esta senadora remonte saint germain
dice es que lo que se necesita no es ese
tipo de campaña pero sino más bien una
campaña de educación de sensibilización
al público en general sobre el peligro
que es latente del consumo de la
marihuana a fin de cuentas pues ese
pulso que se anunciaba no se realizó
porque lo que sucede acá es que los
senadores son designados no son elegidos
son designados por los
los ministros de turno y la cámara de
representantes- ellos los diputados si
son elegidos en breve en voto popular
entonces lo que decía la senadora es que
aunque el senado se hubiera opuesto y lo
hubiera enviado diez veces a la cámara
de representante de la cámara de
representantes se lograran enviado y
hubiera habido una una pérdida de tiempo
ahí y que por esa razón decidieron
finalmente aprobarlo y tratar de manejar
el problema de que ellos juzgan de otra
forma
hay un choque y entre las
reivindicaciones de quebec y el hecho de
que es el poder federal que se reserva
la injerencia sobre todo lo que tiene
que ver o la jurisdicción mejor dicho
sobre todo lo que tiene que ver con
drogas y sustancias de la droga
alguien la semana pasada escuché a
alguien en la radio poner el ejemplo de
qué va a ocurrir cuando por ejemplo las
fuerzas del orden la policía o quien sea
llegue por ejemplo a detener a alguien
aquí en quebec porque está violentando
normas provinciales bueno esa persona
deba poder decir tranquilamente la
policía no yo tengo una ley federal que
me ampara para poder cultivar estas
drogas en mi casa
y que el gobierno federal dijo ya que es
la ley que va a primar y va a haber un
enfrentamiento jurídico entre las
provincias y el gobierno federal que va
probablemente muy probablemente
terminará en la corte suprema perfecto
bueno no perfecto pero gracias en todo
caso que le proporcione que ve que es
clara se opone justamente a que la gente
cultive sus cuatro plantas porque esto
implica la baja de la venta claro que no
no podrá cobrar impuestos claro
y yo robo tu tema si el tema que
propongo nuestros oyentes es un tema que
les va a permitir justamente el conocer
un poco la forma que existe en canadá de
interpretar la libertad religiosa y es
el caso de una universidad en colonia
británica una universidad religiosa que
se llama la trinity university trinity
western y lo que quería hacer trinity
western quiere crear una facultad de
derecho para que esa facultad de derecho
sea para que los títulos otorgados por
esta facultad sean reconocidos por la
profesión en colonia británica y en el
país tiene que contar con la aprobación
del colegio de abogados de esa provincia
ahora en principio si se la dieron pero
will impugnaciones porque es lo que
establece una de las normas que rigen
esta universidad religiosa es que todos
los estudiantes y profesores se tienen
que adherir a un código de conducta que
entre otras cosas prohíbe tanto como
decir disparates hablar mal pero también
prohíbe tener relaciones sexuales fuera
del matrimonio y sobre todo prohíbe
sexuales fuera de las relaciones
heterosexuales el punto de vista de la
impugnación es el siguiente es que en
que nada es legal desde hace unos años
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo entonces de 100 que no vamos a
reconocer la validez de sus títulos
académicos porque justamente son
representa una violación a las
libertades fundamentales el caso fue de
corte en varias instancias jurídicas
hasta llegar a la corte suprema y
finalmente la corte suprema decreto que
es proporcionado y razonable limita los
derechos religiosos a fin de asegurar el
acceso abierto a los estudiantes que son
el gp de homosexuales lesbianas
bisexuales transexuales y el enfoque
justamente es que las a esta profesión
del derecho tiene que reflejar los
cambios en la sociedad
y hubo un momento en que en canadá por
ejemplo era ilegal el homosexual era
ilegal
hubo hubo operaciones policiales contra
clubes homosexuales hubo toda una una
depuración del servicio público
justamente todo empleado que podía tener
tensión sexual es porque se creía que
podía ser víctima de chantajes por los
soviéticos todas esas son historias del
siglo pasado entonces bajo esos
argumentos la corte suprema decide que
week que que no que el colegio de
abogados de con una británica como el
voluntario que también se ponía eso
tienen todo el derecho de no reconocer
los la validez de esos títulos jurídicos
de los títulos universitarios dados por
la universidad que para empezar priva
además de acceso a la profesión a
estudiantes de esas comunidades bueno
perfecto muchas gracias rufo y muy
brevemente porque ya no queda muy poco
tiempo yo les les invito en todo caso a
ver un reportaje que prepare días atrás
sobre un estudio que hizo quisieron
científicos del colegio veterinario de
ontario que está asociado a la
universidad
constataron la presencia en el hígado de
gansos salvajes en la provincia de
ontario de plaguicidas que son
utilizados comúnmente por la industria
que tiene un alto poder tóxico y que ya
habían sido encendidas las alertas
respecto a la el efecto que estas
sustancias tienen por ejemplo sobre las
abejas y otros polinizadores había
habido un estudio si ustedes recuerdan
hace un año un año y pico atrás de
el uso de plaguicidas que afectaban al
vuelo de las abejas les hacían perder el
sentido de la orientación y en algunos
casos incluso ir a distancias mucho más
largas que las habituales o las
debilitadas y en todo entonces eso
además tenía como efecto secundario la
pérdida de capacidad de reproducción de
las abejas no solamente ocurre con estas
especies sino con otras entonces el uso
de estas plaguicidas que son esos
avanzada
sobre todo es peligroso porque además si
se detecta cómo se ha detectado ya el
uso de estos plaguicidas y que afectan a
poblaciones animales que no son el
destinatario del uso de los mismos tarde
o temprano podrían también tener un
efecto sobre las personas y ahí es donde
las alarmas principales se encienden
vamos a una pequeña pausa y ya volvemos
buenos días mi nombre es claudia
saldivia director musical del conjunto
proyecto altiplano y los invito a
escuchar canadá en las américas café de
radio canadá internacional
bueno perfecto colegas en un minuto y
medio no mucho más que eso porque no
hacemos alguna referencia a la fiesta de
la manzana que se celebra este fin de
semana aquí en la provincia de québec y
que implican actos sus celebraciones
importantes para los residentes de aquí
me parece que a simple vista por lo que
conozca de los barrios de biller y san
javier santa león la fiesta de la
sangran que hasta unos años atrás tenía
un corte netamente político en lista
nacionalista se ha convertido algo más
más espectáculo más seddon más hedonista
en el buen sentido de la palabra
disfrutar el verano de compartir y al
final yo creo que eso se refleja
políticamente y este años de elecciones
en la provincia entonces este es allianz
batista va a servir para los partidos
que proponen todavía la cuestión de la
dependencia que ve que es legítima desde
el punto de vista de qué lado soplan los
vientos y probablemente se van a dar
cuenta de qué
el lado independentista de esta fiesta
deshonran sucumbió a los aromas de la
parrillada y los buenos vinos bueno lo
cual me parece
excelente
van de la mano y bueno pues esto puede
ser bueno pero si siempre pues la sénia
es motivo de festejo bueno perfecto como
no nos queda más tiempo ya tenemos que
ir cerrando un simplemente decir que ya
no nigeria mirar o níger y le acaba de
dar una mano a la argentina que ya
estaba casi con un pie cuando juegue
[Música]
[Risas]
ahora argentina le va a tocar un hueso
duro de roer ganarle a nigeria bueno nos
vamos entonces con un poco de música y
la cantante canadiense de origen
filipino y liszt y estrada y su tema
precisamente champions campeón empresa
les bien días de mundial que nos están
viendo riendo
[Música]